Điều đoàn định lực Việt Nam, EVNER, cho biết gió anh vượng của báo số mười đến triệu ngày 20 tháng
chiến đã có khoảng 30 vệ 4 triệu khách hàng tại nhiều tình đến bác và miền Trung bị Mất định.
Tất chung ở thình hoa, nghỉ Anh, Hà Tính, Ninh Bình, Hương In, Phu Thọc, Quảng Chị, Thưa Thien, Khế và Đảnh.
Để hình chương khác phục, tổng công tì đến lực miền bác và miền Trung đã vi động khoảng 20 40, cán mộ,
công nhân cùng nhiều phương tịn từ các đơn vị để lực tại chỗ vào hỗ trợ từ đơn vị bản.
EVNER cho biết, mưa báo kéo dài đã gây ra hàng rà xử cố trên hệ thống chuyển tại định cao áp năm 2020, 1,000 kí lúc vôn.
Đến này, ngành định đã hối phục bẩy trên 15 xí cố trên lối năm 2020, 1 xí xấu trên 15,000 kí lúc vôn và 1,500 xấu xấu xí cố trên lối 2020.
Các nhà máy thủy định trong khu vực vẫn hành hán quanh, hiện có 1 xấu hộ thủy định đang sả tràn địa vui trí dung tích phòng lũ và các sảm lũ cho hả dù.
Trong đó có các hộ lớn như thức bà, chung sơn, bản vẽ, EA li, buôn quốc, hoa mình.
Ngành định khẳng định đang tập trung mọi lực lực phương tịn đi khuối phục cấp định nhàng nhất, hành hành hình đời sống và sản xuất của mình rất nguồn báo.